I guess what's made it hard especially
over the last sort of six months is
that I've been working basically
full-time writing this book
and I suppose to people watching the
channel don't know that so I've had to
kind of fit the YouTube in around the book um
and at the same time as I've been doing that
the YouTube has really grown a lot
so first thing is it's been really
it's been really great to see the YouTube
grow and I'll tell you why because
as you know I've been betting on like gradual
accelerating deterioration of the economy for
a long time right and this is something that I've
had with me like for ages like this knowledge that
the economy will get worse and worse and
um I first realised that as part of my job
and I guess it's a weird situation to be
in like your job is to put on the economy
being bad and you bet on it and the economy is
bad and then you get you make a lot of money
and then you year after year watch the economy
get worse and worse and worse and my situation
was strange right because I was able to make a
lot of money by understanding the economy was bad
and then I quit doing that and I wanted to stop
the economy from being bad and it was almost like
impossible to do it so you can go and you
can work for a bank and you can get paid
more than a million pounds a year to bet on
the economy being bad but if you want to
work for that government for free you can't
if you want to walk into the universities and
talk to the academics and be like listen
can we talk about why the economy is bad
they've got no interest right and it's it's
I I it's quite amazing right I think
the world we live in is quite amazing
that somebody like me can get paid you know when
Iwas in my mid-20s a million pound a year to bet
on the economy being bad but I cannot do anything
to stop the economy from being bad even for free
it's weird it's crazy right it's crazy you would
think that somebody who's worth a million pound a
year to the banks should be worth employing
for free by the government or by the media
um and yet and of course parts of the media have
been supportive you know like Laurie Macfarlane at
Open Democracy printed my first article um although
to be honest who's been supportive beyond that inthe
media I mean we have had some support oh the guys
at Novara have been amazing have been really
supportive and they've pushed us a lot like we're
really grateful for the support they've given us
um but you know they're not the mainstream
media right so it's is difficult
when you know something's happening and you
can make a ton of money knowing that it's
happening but you can't do anything to stopit,
you can't do anything to stop it and I've
wanted to see that for ages and I guess
what the YouTube has finally given me is
an outlet to try and do something that is
positive and I know like so far you know
our influence on actual policy has been limited
and things have been getting worse and worse and
worse um you know we're trying to become
more influential in the labour party and
in the media and in sort of in the political
left and we have our small amount of influence
um but at least what I can do now is I can explain
to people what's happening and I can try and build
a platform such that we can start pushing for like
policy change so it's been amazing to like you
know after a long long time of knowing that things
will get worse and not being able to stop it Ifeel
like now I have some small power to support
people and also a platform on which to build
bigger power um but I guess what
comes with that is the difficulty of
now that you know you can maybe do something
someday then you have to start thinking a lot more
strategically of like okay well maybe you have
a chance now to do something like when I first
started doing this when I first started writing
articles we first made our video it was like we
have to say something you know you just have to
say something so let's try and say something but
now we have a voice and the voice is growing now
it's like well you have an obligation to start to
think a little bit strategically about how can you
build that with how can you build that power such
you can actually make a difference down the line
and then adds another level of pressure on and um
I know because we get a ton of messages
that there are people out there kind of
hoping that we make we manage to make this
work you know you know I get emails from
people sending me their CV like we want to
support, we want to work and I really really
appreciate that at the same time you see
that and it makes you realise like wow like
people are counting on us to try and make a
difference down the line so it becomes like
it becomes stressful and it becomes hard
especially when you consider like so I never
was a writer but the last 9 months I've been throwing
myself into writing this book because I think that
well to be honest at first when I first started
considered writing the book it wasn't the idea was
like this could be a real springboard to use my
personal story which I've tried to avoid using
too much to really like give us a much bigger
platform for the YouTube, for the Instagram,
for all of the social media platforms to push this
message but as I've started writing it like I've
really sort of fallen in love with the process
of writing and I really want to write something
that is that has some beauty and is powerful
and it's emotional and it's been emotional for
me to read and to write but I've been putting
so much of my emotional energy into that book
that then it's hard at the same time to
to bring emotion to the YouTube as well
so I think I guess obviously the guys
watching the YouTube they don't know that like
day after day every single day I'm writing writing
writing they don't realise like I've got that on
the side as well and people sending messages that
you should do this, you should do that, they don't
realise how busy I am you know what I mean
um but yeah it's difficult it's difficult and
um on the subject of it being difficult one
thing I wanted to bring up was again answering
a question that like I get sometimes
which is you know you're a rich guy
why do you care if it's difficult and we were
talking about this earlier right and I think
the first thing is I think people okay and this
is partially my fault I think sometimes people
sometimes overestimate how rich I am, they think
I'm Elon Musk or something you know I'm a rich
guy I made a lotta money in the city but I quit my job
a long time ago I don't have a job I don't have a
regular income so I'm living off of the money
that I saved I don't have enough money to like
build a massive social media build a political
party like sometimes people say we should do but
I think the second thing which I think is
quite interesting is this question of like
if you are rich should you care if you are
rich should you care if people are poor and
you know we were talking about this earlier
and I was saying so people who've watched
this from the start will know I don't come from
a rich background right, I don't come from a
rich family, I don't come from a rich area and
my family and the people I grew up with and
not just that by the people I live my life with in
this city, the people I meet, my friends are not
rich they're not from rich backgrounds right so
they live in this world that we've created now
which is difficult to live in and especially
when you look what's happened the last
couple of years right so we're in London
London rents have gone mental right so now
it's this city is difficult to live in now it's
difficult to live in and I'm not going to name
names but a lot of people very close to
meare just struggling just to get by and
when people say like you're rich why should you
care I think it's easy to say that right but like
does that mean that I don't give a s*** about
my closest friends and family you know what I mean
or just the people that I live my whole life
with in the city you know I mean like I think
the thing which one of the things which most
upsets me about the inequality that we live in
is I think that we are now more and more
creating a society whereas an individual
your only options in life are to be poor or to be
separated from humanity that is the reality of a
vastly unequal society you because most people
are poor right and you know increasingly we're
seeing more and more people which is it's not
just relative poverty you know we're talking
about people struggling to pay the bills to pay
the rent right and the more unequal society gets
the more that's your choice right, you're either with
themajority and you're poor or you're secure but
you're separated from society and I think
increasingly we're living in a world where
everyone is and has to be to some degree one of
those things you know what I mean like I was poor
growing up and now I'm financially secure but
what that means is I'm I'm separate from other
people because other people are struggling
more and more see what I'm saying and um
that's the world that we live in and that's the
world that we are creating and it's and I feel
the stress of just the difficulty
of simple basic questions like
where am I gonna, where am I gonna live, where
amI gonna live? next month where am I gonna live?
what's going to happen if my landlordputs the
rent up? what's gonna happen if my landlord
kicks me out, where am I going to live?these
questions simple questions like am I going
to be able to afford to have a family? these
questions you know these are questions which
you know no matter if I can afford those things
you know what am I going to do am I going to pay
for all my friends and family to have a family and
even if I was to do that right which I couldn't
afford to do right even if I was to do that even
if I was to pay for like all of my family and my
10 closest friends have their families right then
what happens when I go out the door and I walk
down the high street it's still full of these
people who are struggling and I think it's it's
I think it's I understand it right because you
know I was poor and I think when you are poor
when I was poor, you have this idea in your head
and I had this idea in my head, if I had money
everything would be fine and that's the idea I had
right and this is in some senses this is the story
of my life that I made that money and I always
thought if you make the money you'll be fine and
I wasn't fine because you still live in this world
with the people who are in this world you know I
mean you're still living with this world of youknow
like your closest friends are insecure youknow
what I mean? the girls that I date you know what I
mean they're insecure you know and they have this
stress you know I mean and the young people
around me like they live in nowadays like if
you're young there's two types of jobs right, a job
that you can't pay the bills and a job where you
you have no time to sleep you know what I mean
those are the two types of jobs young people do
and I live in the world full of young people that
either can't eat or can't sleep you know what I
mean and is that is that a good world to live
in and I see it getting worse and worse so um
you know that is that is the thing that I see
and every day I'm aware that I don't have those
struggles you know like of paying the bills
but I still live in this world so it's sort of
yeah it's it's difficult and I'm not you know
I'm not asking people to play the violins for
me I know it's difficult but it is um it's hard
sometimes it's hard knowing that you have a voice
and wondering how to grow, and like now we're at
the kind of point with the with the channel where
I can't read them I can't read the messages
anymore you know for a long time it was like
I'll reply to every message and then it was like
I don't reply to every message but I read every
message you know and now it's like I can't even
read every message and it's like then and now
I'm starting to think like if it's going to grow
bigger and we want it to grow bigger and I've got
plans to make it grow bigger like up until now
like I haven't made any money from the YouTube
you know what I mean and that's fine I don't
expect to make any money from the YouTube but
it's getting to the point now but we're gonna
need support we're gonna need I'm gonna I'm
gonna need support, I'm gonna need people
there to be able to read the messages for
me and let me know what's going on and look out
for opportunities we can do so that I can focus
on writing and making the videos you know what
I mean and then I need to think about how we're
going to do that how we're going to finance that
how is it going to grow so yeah it's a lot it's an
you know I'm super happy I'm super excited but
then at the same time I'm also thinking like
so there are probably some people that will
say and I see them saying oh he's doing this
because he wants to just get that he wants to
get known he wants to get like famous he wants
to get celebrity or whatever right so you know
I quit my job in 2014 and I didn't start this
YouTube channel till 2020, and before that I've
volunteered at think-tanks, I made the website
I did a two-year Masters at Oxford because and
the truth is all through all of that I knew
in my heart of hearts that realistically our
best chance at changing policy would be to make
an online platform pushing, using my story and
my face, pushing it to ordinary people to try
and build a public platform I always
knew that but I didn't want to do that
because I didn't want to try and well to be honest
like I wasn't really sure I was comfortable with
getting famous you know what I mean but now
like when the book comes out next year the
aim is that, we don't know if it'll work or not but
the aim, is to try to build a big platform you know
and I need to think like what does that mean for
me? what does that mean for my life? you know like
because at the moment it's just been me and you
and like for the people that don't know the guy
that runs the channel you Simran is a friend
of mine from high school we've been friends for
25 years now um but if it's going to get big then
it's going to need to be more people you know I
mean it's gonna and it's just gonna be I'm gonna
have to start managing people and it's just like
there's so much to think about and at the
same time like I'm getting these creative
opportunities like writing the book like making
the videos but also I need to start thinking about
the business side of things the financing side
of things and also the messages are coming in
so it's like basically it's hard and um we I think
it's hard just to find the time because if
we're going to grow then I need to really
sit down and make a business plan basically
make a financing plan make a plan about like
who are we going to hire what
are they going to do you know um
but like I don't have the time to do that with
the writing the book with like publicising the
book but they did in the book with also making
the videos so we'll probably have to stop doing
the videos at some point so we can make a proper
plan for growth make a proper plan for hiring
so yeah it's a lot it's a lot to think
about but what I would like to say is that
I'm super grateful even though I've said
I don't have time to read all the messages
now and it breaks my heart a little bit
to say that because I would love to read
all the messages but I'm super grateful for
all the positive messages that we get because
the bigger the channel grows the more we
get negative messages and as much as I would
like to be like you know 'I don't care about negative
messages' you read them and you see them and they
do stick with you but you know we are lucky that
for every 1 negative message there's there's 25-30
positive messages and you know when I'm walking
out I get stopped in the street and everyone has
something positive to say so as much as I've
said like I'm not sure about becoming famous
that is important it's important that we get that
positive stuff because because otherwise it would
be hard to keep doing this you know what I mean
and I think like people see the channel growing
and growing and they're like well done it's great
but they don't realise most of my days are in here
in that room writing the book in here filming
videos in here planning videos like it's very
it's quite isolating and it's quite it's quite a
lonely work you know what I mean like it's we
started doing Covid when there was no one around
um so those messages that we get are important
um because they keep me motivated I'm
sure they keep you motivated as well um
but I think what I would like to say is that
recently I've been thinking more about how
do we grow it big because I think we do have a
chance to to listen I didn't start this to be
a guy on YouTube I started this because I want
to reduce inequality and I know that's not easy
but I think we have a chance to be a part of that
and what I will say for sure 100% sure is you will
see political change in the next 10-15 years, big
political change, the reason I say that is because
the speed at which living standards are falling
have fallen in the last 2-3 years it'smassive
and I don't think they'll keep fallingat that speed
but from here they're going to keepfalling
quickly and people are going to be mad,
people are gonna be mad, people are going to
be angry, people are going to be scared, people
are going to be insecure and they're going to
vote for change and in most cases because we're
in a situation where the political mainstream
is just unable to provide serious change and
I'm not talking about just the UK here this
is international you know you're going to see
you know there was an election in Finland the
other day and they voted at the centre-left and
they vote in the center-right those guys are not
going to improve things, we've got an election
here next year where we're going to vote out the
conservatives & vote in labour probably realistically
those guys are not going to improve things right
if people keep voting in centre left,
centre right, centre left, centre right
and seeing deterioration deterioration they
will vote for change they will vote for change
and we could get positive change
and we could get negative change
and we are in a position where if we grow this we
could be one of those people that push ordinary
people in the direction of positive change better
living standards because I guarantee you right now
the other side is gonna, I know what they're
gonna do, I know what they're going to do,
they're going to try and sow divisionamongst
the general public between people who
own property & people who don't, betweenthe
native white people & the immigrants youknow
they're going to try and sow like racial based,
you could see that in the in what's happening now
you can see that's all over the newspapers
right now in the way that they talk about
refugees and the way that they mix them in with
economic migrants, this kind of stuff, you cansee
that's going to happen, they're going to tryand build
more animosity between the older & the young
they're going to try and build animositybetween
the North & the South, and it will be thesame in
every country that is the direction that
they're going to push things in and if they win
then you know you're going to see some really
problematic change in society and at the same time
the economic situation is going to get worse so
I think that there will be change and I think we
we can make it positive change you know people
there's a lot of fatalism I see in the messages
where people say oh it was always that way it's
always that way it's the problem with human nature
you know what I mean and listen our parents
neither of our parents neither of your parents
neither of my parents have university degrees right
andthey were able to buy property, raise families
it was possible 40-50 years ago so things change,
things change, and our our grandparents and our
great grandparents were poor, things change things
change in a positive way for our parents right
and now they're changing a negative way
for our generation & for generations in the
future and the reason that things change in a
positive way is because people push for it and
that brings me to my final point that
I want to end this on right which is
I was out the other day at a friend's birthday
party I think he was 50. he's older than me
so people know um and I was talking to one of his
nephews and the nephew was like tell me like how
do I make money trading he watches the channel
right 'how do i make money trading?' and this
is the thing that we get a lot on the channel howdo
i make money trading, how do we, and of course okay
everybody who watches the channel knows um was
formerly avery successful professional trader I still trade
I still make money and we have a few videos about
trading on the channel and the general message
is don't f***ing trade don't trade because it's
dangerous man it's dangerous it's gambling you
can lose money and of course people turn around
they're like well you do it you know what I mean
and you know I was a professional I did because
I was a professional because I was one of the
best people in the world at it, I think I still
am one of the best people in the world at it
so I trade you know you know this is why why does
Lionel Messi play football because he's damn good
you know what I mean like I trade because this is
my profession this is my skill this is what I've
trained 20 years for you know what I mean um and
what I try and tell him it's like I tried to sayyou
know he, I don't know how old he was he could
have been 18-19 and what I said to him listen
the only way for you to protect yourself
your family your community your future
is to learn how to politically engage with
your friends in your wider community because
you cannot beat the rich as individuals you
cannot but with we've created society that
trains our young people into like hustle for you
hustle for you hustle for you hustle for you and
this is the perfect mindset to completely
enable the rich to take everything because
let's say like I'm a rich guy and I'm the
strongest guy in the room I'm 10 times
as stronger as anyone else in the room
and I walk into a room full of athousand
people and my plan is to take all theassets
of everyone in that room what do I want
I want these guys to fight me one at a time right
that's it if these guys fight me one at a time
I'll be every single one of them one at a time
and if these guys are unable to politically unite
then they will lose everything they will lose
everything that is and it's so I think we we
have in a sense a cultural problem in our society
and and I understand it because I was the same
when I was younger when I was poor myself I was
out to look after me you know and because no one
else was looking after me I understand it but if
people in poor and ordinary financial situations
are not able to look beyond their front
garden and towards their wider community
and say listen we need to get together and
start acting as a group then every single one
of them individually will lose what they have over
time so it is a question of can we unite, can we
politically you know and there's people have been
saying you know we need to put a call to action in the
videos and there was a period where we were doing
that, do you remember what the call to action was
right it was three things it was three things
right the first thing was understand what's
happening understand what's happening and you know
the reason that I stopped doing mainstream media
or I do much less is because I would go on talk
radio I'll go on LBC and I would fight with some
guy from some right wing think-tank you know what
I mean and yeah sometimes I would win you know and
then I would I would put down the phone put down a
zoom call and I would be like okay you had a fight
on the radio who was educated who was educated
the way that we win is by providing ordinary
working class people with an understanding of
the situation the truth of the matter is ifthings
keep going the way they're going and thereis no
systemic change then the whole of the bottom
70-80% will be dispossessed they will lose their
assets they'll fall into poverty if that 70-80%
understand it they will vote against it and we can
change the situation so number one was understand
number two was share the message and the reason
I said that is because it is only through building
communities that we can win, we cannot win as
individuals, I cannot win this as an individual you
know I'm going to try and build as much as I can
but I cannot win this as an individual, none of us can
we can none, we're not going to beat Rupert Murdoch
you know we're not going to beat the billionaires
we're never going to be billionaires but together
we can still exert our power but only together
we can only win together so it's number one educate
yourselves it was number two share the message and
it was number three push back and I see people
saying how do we push back how do we push back
but we need to be strong enough we need to be strong
enough we need to be enough of us and we need to
understand it so we need to build the message we
need to grow it and then when we have it then we
will push we'll push we'll push through political
means if we can and if it has to be other ways
then we'll look at other ways but we need to be
strong enough and at the moment the working class
is is too divided and there are too many people
that are just looking for their own thing and not
willing to organise beyond that politically and I
understand that and I would never say to anybody
come support us and don't look after your family
look after your family look after yourself but
you need to be willing and able to open your
mind to those bigger political possibilities
um but if we do that we can win and we have to
win and there will be change there will be change
and positive change has happened before you know
look what happened after the Second World War
you know for the first time ever we had countries
across Europe also in the United States where
ordinary working people could get good quality
housing, education, healthcare, food, leisure time
these things were possible 70 years ago they're
possible now but we're losing them but we won
them before and we can win them again but we can
only win them together so yeah I would encourage
everybody watching to support the channel follow
us share us um we're going to be trying to work
out how to build that it might mean that we need
to take a bit of time out it might need to start
looking at how we're going to fund it long term
but um we're still here and we'll keep pushing